sii il cambiamento che vuoi vedere nel
mondo è una frase che io amo molto
è una frase che mi porto in giro nel mio
ufficio mi segue dappertutto ma mano che
cambi ufficio ma sono anche fatta
stampare e qua dietro sulla mia
maglietta per darmi un po di coraggio
questa sera è una frase che mi parla
perché è davvero io credo come tutti voi
tutti in questa stanza che cambiare il
mondo sia necessario che questo mondo in
cui viviamo non sia particolarmente
bello che abbia bisogno di aggiustamenti
ci sono troppe ingiustizie però una
frase che mi parla perché in realtà mi
ha fornito una risposta perché spesso la
domanda è se io vorrei vedere un mondo
diverso ma come posso fare
e in questa frase sii il cambiamento che
vuoi vedere nel mondo
la risposta c'è il cambiamento sono io
il cambiamento è una qualsiasi persona
assoluto in questa stanza
il cambiamento è la persona che decide
di cambiare e cambiando cambia il mondo
ed è una frase che se ci pensate non è
così nelle nostre corde non è così
facile per noi capirla perché siamo
molto abituati a pensare al cambiamento
come qualcosa di già realizzato a
vederlo lì a vedere un a vederlo anche
in modo fisico invece il cambiamento
sottostimiamo il fatto che può essere un
processo un processo che parte il
cambiamento sempre ha un inizio e questo
inizio può essere innescato da qualcosa
e noi con la nostra testa così razionale
così abituata a pesare le cose a volerle
vedere non riusciamo a capire le
potenzialità che c'è nell'innesco di
qualcosa nella la partenza di qualcosa
nel contagio nel fatto che quando noi
facciamo qualcosa qualcuno ci guarda io
ho sempre amato vestirmi in modo
colorato molto colorato lo faccio perché
mi piace molto mi dà un piacere fisico
la mattina sceglierà dall'armadio un
capo con un colore caldo mi metto molta
allegria
mi piace soprattutto in contesti in cui
comunque avere un colore diverso afferma
un po una diversita che va portata
avanti
un giorno un giorno conosciuto avivah
wittenberg cox non so se la conoscete di
sicuro la conoscete lei una guru della
leadership femminile e lei mi disse una
cosa molto importante di sé quando io
faccio lo speech quando entro in
un'azienda
la prima cosa che guardo è come sono
colorate le donne e da li capisco che
tipo di spazio di manovra o che grado di
maturità c'è in azienda e quindi vado a
dare un feedback anche in relazione al
grado di colore che vedono e l'audience
per me fu una specie di rivelazione per
me fu una una rimasi stupito da questa
cosa io stavo indossando un colore e
stavo cercando di dio di essere diversa
di soddisfarlo che piacere c'era
qualcuno che aveva in mano le leve del
potere che aveva in mano la possibilità
davvero di cambiare magari parlando col
management che in base al mio colore
decideva che tipo di comportamento di
che di cambiamento portare in azienda
per me fu davvero una specie di
rivelazione anni fa nell'azienda in cui
lavoravo decidemmo di lavorare
pesantemente sulle donne eravamo molto
consci del fatto che più donne in
azienda i ruoli altri avrebbero davvero
cambiato questa azienda
ebbi la fortuna di incontrare un manager
illuminato una persona visionaria di
quelle che davvero si incontrano e non
si dimenticano mai molto capace di
vedere il cambiamento di di volerlo con
forza e con intensità ma al tempo stesso
di ascoltare con grande umiltà e di
lasciare lo spazio a chi sapeva fare le
cose che lui non sapeva fare
lui mi chiamò e mi disse chiara dobbiamo
fare qualcosa per le donne e io mi
ricordo la scena come se fosse adesso
era seduto davanti alla scrivania e
avevo il foglio in mano e la penna
perché allora non c'erano life ambiente
e chiesi cosa vuoi che io faccia e lui
mi guardò e disse carta bianca e io in
quel momento di nuovo e di una specie di
tuffo al cuore carta bianca una specie
di possibilità infinito di fare qualcosa
e quindi da lì risi carta bianca quando
una carta bianca cosa fa bene allora
prova a pensare a se stessa
sii il cambiamento che vuoi vedere del
mondo io cosa voglio e subito mi fu
chiaro voglio essere una madre
avevo due figli allora che lavora in
azienda che che riesce davvero a
conciliare queste infinite stati dei
miei bambini che non finivano mai col
fatto che in azienda volevo portare
avanti progetti strategici
che riesce a mettere insieme il fatto di
non mancare neanche un momento
importante ma neanche un saggio dei
propri bambini
io volevo essere quello che mi sento di
essere una donna completa rotonda 360 a
360 gradi
io so e volti che hanno avuto figli
sanno che si può essere davvero così
rotonde e così piene da far convivere
due vite nella stesso corpo e non c'è
problema con due vite noi comunque
andiamo avanti io volevo quello e quindi
fu molto chiaro su cosa lavorare però
non ero ovviamente in grado di farla da
sola e quindi chi ha mai tutte le altre
donne
eravamo tanto in azienda fu divertente
perché usciamo da questo dal nostro dal
nostro ufficio tutte insieme di colpo
senza dire dove andava ma iniziamo a
chiederci tutti insieme cosa vogliamo
cosa vogliamo essere e riparti questo
processo che era partito da me ecc
ascoltammo iniziamo iniziamo a fare
delle cose strane andammo a pranzo e poi
facendo una corsa insieme è davvero che
sembrava che non avessimo un programma e
ci chiedevano ma qual è il vostro
programma non ce l'avevamo però stavamo
iniziando ad ascoltarci a noi a essere
diverse a capire cosa avremmo potuto
fare a distanza di anni nella mia
azienda ci sono le flessibilità più
spinte tutti i passaggi possibili
immaginabili cioè il lavoro agile ci
sono piani di sussex infatti con le
donne con le cose dall'interno dei piani
ci sono programmi di manager c'è tutto è
tutto ma io ricordo con grande emozione
il fatto che partivo da noi
sii il cambiamento che vuoi vedere nel
mondo ci chiedemmo noi come cose come
vanno come vorremmo essere e cambiamo la
nostra azienda un po di anni fa ai
quattro anni fa il sindaco di milano fu
oggetto di una richiesta di cambiamento
fortissimo tutta la città voleva
cambiare e lui incorporò a questo
cambiamento lo rispose a questo
cambiamento è deciso di fare una giunta
dove non ci fossero solo persone
delegate da dei partiti ma anche persone
della società civile
mi chiamò mi chiamò e disse vuoi
partecipare a questa cosa e di sì certo
con grande gioia lo farò con grande
gioia
anche lì questa istanza di cambiamento
mi arriva addosso e il sindaco con la
volta non è che mi disse al carta bianca
mi disse solo quello lì è il tuo ufficio
poi non lo vidi più e quindi di nuovo mi
trovai da sola a dire loro cosa faccio è
di nuovo mi torna mente questa frase si
il cambiamento è come vedere del mondo
pensate che cittadina vuoi essere e
quindi ripensai che quello che volevo
che avevo visto nella mia azienda potevo
anche provare a portarlo in città e poi
come tutti quando vengono lasciati da
soli
feci quello che sapevo fare e quindi
ripartita al lavoro agile e lavoro agile
in questi anni a milano è diventato
davvero un'aria di lavoro molto
importante di questo io sono molto molto
soddisfatta il lavoro agile è davvero la
chiave così semplice di tantissimi
problemi e io tra l'altro lo vorrei dire
qua con un po di di forza non credo che
sia più il tempo di rispondere alle
domande che mi fanno gli altri perché si
deve fare il lavoro agile io credo che
sia il tempo che vari manager o
direttore del personale rispondano a me
perché non fa il lavoro agile perché
davvero i vantaggi a livello di azienda
ormai sono misurati da tutte le
università con cui lavoriamo da dagli
esperimenti che abbiamo fatto e sono
vantaggi a livello di abbattimento degli
straordinari dell'assenteismo di
diminuzione dei costi degli uffici
davvero non è tempo di parlare di quello
i vantaggi per la città sono anche
quelli misurati ormai da due anni e sono
chiarissimi diminuiscono le macchine di
unisce la co2 migliora l'aria c'è più di
così cosa si deve dimostrare credo che i
vantaggi di tutti siano però la
centralità della persona il fatto che se
si concede il lavoro agile si tratta la
persona come un essere capace di
mettersi al centro della propria vita
autodeterminarsi e quindi gestirsi il
proprio tempo e una delle notizie più
belle per cui ogni volta che mi
entusiasmo quando misuriamo il lavoro
agile e che mediamente per quanto una
media possa valere le persone recuperano
due ore di tempo
due ore di tempo davvero se qualcuno mi
regalasse ogni giorno due ore di tempo
davvero saprei cosa fare ognuno di voi
credo che saprebbe cosa fare però queste
due ore di tempo sono quelle che si
permette che ci permettono di collegare
questa frase che per me
così e così importante sii il
cambiamento che vuoi vedere nel mondo lo
devi essere tu devi anche avere il tempo
per farlo quindi due ore di tempo
permettono alle persone di provare ad
attivare quello che loro stesse possono
fare semplicemente cercando loro di
essere diverse e se davvero se si
ragiona su questo nesso tra tempo
liberato tra questa possibilità infinita
che abbiamo con le no quei nostri
comportamenti con i nostri sogni con i
nostri desideri di incidere così
profondamente sulla realtà che cambia se
si ragiona su questo si mette questo
sistema
io credo che si possa un po raccontare
quello che sta succedendo a milano
meno di un mese fa perché davvero
neanche passato un mese ci furono ci fu
un atto violentissimo in città arrivano
questi black blocks e davvero fecero uno
scempio di un pezzo della nostra città
io ho ancora negli occhi quelle immagini
bruttissimi levi di alla tele coi miei
figli eravamo quasi incollati di roma
questo ma che cos'è non è non siamo noi
qualcosa di diverso e non lo pensavo
solo i miei figli per fortuna lo
pensarono 20mila cittadini milanesi che
semplicemente semplicemente scesero
nelle strade fecero a ritroso questo
stesso percorso che avevano fatto i
black box è semplicemente camminando
essendo loro stessi dissero no milan è
un'altra cosa e se andiamo a quel
momento lì forse la cosa bella
fu anche questo tipo di reazione non
solo scendere camminare e dire
semplicemente con il proprio corpo o no
è un'altra cosa noi non siamo quella
cosa lì ma soprattutto vedere questi
ragazzi ragazzi giovani che poi l'ha
buttata sul ridere e per cui per noi
non so se succede anche voi ma è così
normale vedere i ragazzi verso il muro
immaginarseli che lo stanno imbrattando
e vedere che invece di ogni modo delle
spugnette li stanno pulendo sii il
cambiamento che vuoi vedere del mondo
credo che questo abbia una una potenza
che davvero commuove però se devo
scegliere una foto e questa è
irresistibile questa irresistibile e non
si può non si può tirarsi via da una
foto come questa
io mi commuovo anche un po perché lei è
il cambiamento che noi vogliamo vedere
nel mondo lei è lì è una bambina
evidentemente di seconda generazione non
credo che abiti nelle strade dove è
successo quello che è successo e se
guardate bene la foto lei ha un piccolo
lo spazzolino in mano lei col suo
spazzolino in mano sta cambiando il
mondo lei sta pulendo l'intera città
come si può resistere una foto del
genere come possono le istituzioni non
immediatamente fare qualcosa affinché il
suo sforzo non vada perso lei è il
cambiamento che verrà nel mondo
quello fu un momento straordinario per
milano una specie di punto da cui non si
torna indietro oppure se veramente
vediamo il cambiamento come qualcosa di
cui non sappiamo le logiche e i tempi
quei balzi dove le città a un certo
punto fanno un balzo in avanti però
credo che se noi torniamo a queste due
ore e siamo convinti che ognuno di noi
può essere il cambiamento che vuol
vedere nel suo mondo ci sono tante cose
meno emblematiche ma straordinari che si
possono fare ve li cito solo qualcuno il
gioco nei cortili il diritto al gioco
nei cortili è un piccolo diritto certe
volte fa ridere dire che i diritti sono
piccoli perché secondo me neanche i
diritti si pesano ma spesso trascurato e
spesso i bambini di milano non possono
esercitarlo non possono giocare dei loro
cortili
credo che se uno crede fermamente a
questa frase sono io il cambiamento che
voglio vedere nel mondo
beh qui può iniziare a scendere nel suo
cortile di casa a prendere una palla
anche gli adulti con una palla non
resistono e si mettono a giocare portare
le carte fare quello che volete
mettetevi a giocare nel vostro cortile
perché è stata iniziando a difendere un
diritto e nel frattempo
l'amministrazione ha fatto due modifiche
al regolamento per cui avete poi tutti
gli appigli amministrativi e giuridici
per difendere questo diritto
ma bisogna iniziare a scendere e giocare
nel proprio cortile c'è tutto un altro
filone su cui si può lavorare le scuole
aperte
noi tutti sappiamo che la scuola un
patrimonio della città e bisogna aprirla
e molto di più è però è difficile se la
burocrazia e ci sono i custodi manca
riscatto è davvero difficile allora
bisogna andarci nella scuola aprirla e
stare dentro perché se sei il
cambiamento come vedere nel mondo il
mondo cambia
nel frattempo chi può decidere chi
governa la città mette dei soldi per i
progetti e quindi quello che sembra un
gesto individuale diventa immediatamente
un filone su cui si lavora è la città
cambia e poi possa andare avanti a
parlarvi del verde perché è
straordinario quello che sta succedendo
milano le persone stanno prendendo dei
pezzettini di terra si chiama
collaborazione dal punto di vista
amministrativo e lavorano la terra e
cambiano e mettono le loro fiori e
cambia il volto di milano perché sono
stufi di vedere una città brutta e
cambiano loro e cambiano la loro città e
vi faccio forse l'ultimo esempio
questa è una signora che si svegliava al
mattino e vedeva questa cosa sotto casa
e lei non voleva essere triste il
mattino quando si sveglia lei voleva
essere felice quando si sveglia al
mattino
finestra e quindi cosa ha deciso di fare
di mettersi a posto questo giardino
quest'oggi un giardino condiviso
si chiama il giardino nascosto
all'amministrazione nel frattempo ha
fatto tutti gli atti amministrativi per
poterli fare diventare una realtà
ma è la signora che ha iniziato a
coinvolgere i suoi vicini di casa e ha
detto basta io non posso vedere questo
sotto casa e oggi lei la signora si
affaccia e vede questo
questo è un giardino condiviso e una
delle perle della nostra città perché la
signora il mattino ha detto io voglio
essere felice e vedere il verde e se
messa a curarlo e oggi succede questo e
succede anche questo perché poi in città
esistono fenomeni come piano city e
questo giardino nascosto ma vi ricordate
che cos'era oggi asp l'altro giorno ha
ospitato un momento di pianoforte con la
gente che guardava e la signora che ha
voluto essere qualcosa che ha cambiato
il suo mondo lei a lei ci ha provato ci
è riuscita
io sono così convinta di questa frase
sono così convinta che ogni persona che
seduta in questa stanza deve avere
questa consapevolezza deve sapere che se
lei o lui cambia il mondo immediatamente
o in un tempo più lungo cambia con lei
io vi prego di essere davvero
consapevole di questa forza che minuti
di noia e di non pensarla con le nostre
schemi mentali non non pensate a quello
pensate alla potenza del vostro
cambiamento di cosa può succedere in
città
io ho raccontato un po la mia storia ho
cercato di darvi qualche esempio però
sono anche a disponibile se mi fate
solite farmi delle domande a rispondere
perché se doveste chiedervi come ho
fatto io ai miei tempi al mio capo del
mio capo ma va bene siamo convinti ma
che cosa dobbiamo fare
io la risposta molto chiara molto
semplice tre parole ce lo avete carta
mia amica